and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 55 and it's
another glorious Sunday we are back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day we've
got a very special guest God of War
leaks Microsoft cloud gaming division
Xbox updated III presents the Red Dead
to affect and Toys R Us to discuss so we
couldn't get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord cause laid-back and
sarcastic approach to gaming is a
refreshing change in these gaming
streets this Lord is also a huge
multi-platform gamer never afraid to
tackle controversial topics it's similar
to the ILP we have a lord of the arcade
quarter who respects the retro roots of
gaming introducing the co-founder of the
four guys with quarters podcast and a
panelist of the crossfire podcast the
Lord of critical observations and the
man responsible for the petition to put
loot boxes little boxes back in Star
Wars Battlefront to you into the realm
of the Lord's mommy Lord Italian clouds
how you doing sir
hey what's up guys pleasure to be here I
uh I like to throw them sitting on
thanks I appreciate it
absolute pleasure to have you join
inferno usiness Lord Assassin's ivory
fries the crew yummy but I'm glad to
have you in the realm of the Lord's you
know you huge fan of it thanks man
absolutely and of course we have the
force but of gaming we actually baby one
horseman down we got to see what's going
on at he's got some stuff going on a
Murray situation
shout out to him but of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience in also the sastra
Damas
it's the off love profile Illuminati
himself Bobby Lord sovereign are we
doing sir - a fantastic man good to be
here
good to be here good to feel good to be
feeling a hundred percent gonna kick and
I got into it a little bit playful like
you know what the thing is I don't think
I've ever publicly addressed it but this
is it for me
talk to me I think as excited as we all
were when halo 2 dropped years ago right
I think that night a little piece of me
died me those sad bats essentially when
the Saturday night at Cog needles house
Oh me for me that interacts with my
friends is what especially and let's
keep it even more real now at the time
in my life when when the home situation
was not the greatest right that was my
escape my fact I was here with you guys
and I sucks about everything else and
then when it became everything online it
was just like what hey man it's not the
same for me I never came back from that
right now I'm in a great place in my
life but I just I got to a point where
it's like and I don't like so he gets on
my back cuz I don't I don't be online
I don't play online with everybody else
and I'm always in the corner playing a
single big profile invisible longer I'm
gonna I'm gonna put out this this
lifeline right now let's go we got a way
out coming next week okay let's do it
you already know it does that's us
I knew that from day one
listen I know exactly where you were
going with this whole joint and you know
what I'm gonna say the same thing i'ma
reiterate that with you mom in that
situation when that happened
not everybody seemed to like spread out
like a water before we was in a cup and
somebody you know broke the glass halo
broke the glass and it just you know
everybody scattered into the winds who
don't understand what this one days
means like this Sunday means we're
giving you a peek of us you know like
really our group is very vast with very
different personalities that made
everything come together to a point that
if you think this podcast is fun with
the three of us if you can imagine 16 of
us the clowns it was crazy clowns like
it's like a world record this is how we
used to do it man like when it when it
came to halo 1 and we were doing we were
linking up systems we had 4 X boxes with
4 controllers of peace with with the
Linksys router in the middle we have
people we had people on TVs we had four
TVs in different parts because Cognito
had like a like a little mini suite so
we could all spread out a little bit we
have four rooms in the closet over here
we have TV watch whoever didn't perform
well had 13 cat5 we spent break for this
really but let me get my intro
and of course we have the access game
the lord of combat sports it was a man
of his convictions demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
tiki torch extinguish any o beloved Lord
gay guy you do exhibit I am doing
fantastic this Sunday and I'm gonna let
you know a couple of things people we're
doing things different today today we're
gonna do things a little bit different I
have to take a step back because the
other day I woke up to a hundred tweets
that I was in mentions and and I had to
go down he's gonna go why grown men were
in a feelings why grown men felt the
need to express itself in this manner
now we had combat sports last night but
today we're gonna do a little bit
different combat sport villains combat
sports becomes you know this is Sunday
and being a disciple of the Sun God rah
the Sun is gonna shine on your back you
up and I'm gonna give you a hug because
we have a lot of broken individuals out
here that are in their feelings with
certain things and let me tell you
something when we do podcasts if you do
a podcast I may not agree with your
content I mean I know your content but
being at you a fellow podcaster I
embrace you a handshake and a hug we are
brothers we are in the same struggle at
all times
great we are looking for the same likes
and the same viewers and we want our
word to be heard at no point in time do
I have pre prejudices against any
podcaster if I don't know meet with your
content
I just don't view your content but I
support you wholeheartedly because it is
a struggle it takes everything in you to
get up and to do it and to talk and to
be heard absolutely everybody wants to
be heard everybody has an opinion and we
should respect that opinion now church
on to the games I want you to close your
mind all
from the noise outside and I want you to
remember that first time you picked up
the game that love we all [ __ ] they love
this inside of every last one of us I'm
inside of you that's why I embrace you
and I hug you and I call you brother
because we both fell in love with the
same mistress the time charm or him
depending on your situation we taste it
we chase it with such a figure that we
anticipate dates that we can't get
intimate with him given the situation
let me tell you something
close your eyes and remember if you can
go back far enough when you walked in an
arcade and that was your video game
experience that was young taste that was
your love you walked in arcade there was
no box that that controlled your world
he wasn't bound to some piece of plastic
it was a red versus blue it was you
versus that dude and you had that
quarter and you said and then you study
things like man and you shook hands out
the words cuz he beat you you said I
gotta get better I gotta come back cuz
he's the king of the arcade and you know
to do was nice when he put his
quarterback I want you to I want you to
remember when games came out you brought
the best version I brought Street
Fighter 5 times understand I'm a lover
of games yes sir
so it's not about that box close your
eyes and say to yourself if they took
your favorite franchises and put it on
other box would you not be ashamed it's
not about that box it's not about a
person
talking about my playstation you don't
work for the company you employ them
Sony Microsoft boss Joe dollars they can
not operate so stop acting like a peon
and act like a king and a boss oh man we
did the Holy Spirit of irritates me the
most is if you are directly having
conversation with one person
the tribalism and another man that feels
that he has to step up for the next men
line your business unless spoken to you
understand understand that no man needs
defend him because every man stands on
his own and he doesn't need a team
unless calling for help you make your
people look weak by jumping in out of
turn mind your business
in the Lord's realm I am a king then
King David means something and if you
don't know it's all through the Bible if
you go for that it's all through the
world if you go for that
that man was given to me I didn't pick
it up it was an ax Monica that I said
today I feel this way let me tell you
something everybody is respected until
disrespect is involved then I will Sun
you and put you in your place
a new Twitter beef come out I say this
to say remember you are my brother
thanks we all embrace you with a
handshake and a warm hug there we go
it's all love until you make it
something different they know me to know
that me we come from the D
of videogames get out of that box
tribalism that box owes you nothing
repay that box because if you walk in
your house and you turn the box on with
no games what happened nothing a black
screen that's what happens so just
remember you loved the game man loved
the game back we just plays the game
preciate you look King now was have you
sermon to the church today you know yeah
did we have to drop that knowledge and
sorry to turn around so you know we had
to get some things off our chest some
things we've been seeing you know a very
important message by looking all jokes
aside you know we love everybody man as
long as you're a gamer as long as you
got passion for this thing that we love
this is the thing that kept us together
all these years and soft made a good
point you know I understand his thing
with the whole you know there's always
like Xbox Live split us apart anyway as
we got older but it brought us together
at least we can still communicate and
the Iowa podcast also helps us get back
to those fateful Saturday so much
appreciated Lord King and of course it
is law [ __ ] veto here spreading that
gaming realness on an ILP now telling
you what you want to hear but what you
need to hear so before we get into what
the Lords are playing this week I want
to start off with Lord clowns his video
game system history what led him to the
co-creation of one of my favorite
podcasts the four guys with quarters and
of course being a panelist on the
crossfire podcast what clowns let's
start from the beginning or the first
kind of like video game systems that you
had Wow well to be honest my dad had a
couple of pizza places so I was three
years old and it was pac-man young I was
three years old and he put that quarter
in and I fell in love with games ever
since then man wow that's a dope story
at dough so you you are literally a
child of the arcade yes that is
beautiful usha father's salute it's a
little proper clowns that's amazing okay
thanks that's a wait where do we go also
as that infatuation act that love
started with you stuck in the arcade for
a while and and where was the first like
a console that you had um at home my mom
then got me into ColecoVision
we had a ColecoVision we had the sears
version of the atari 2600
i think it was called like the telegram
or something telogen was called it's
just basically the 2600 but it's like a
knockoff it looks the same and it plays
all the same games it worked
version it was just to see Estella game
it was a it was a knockoff it was but it
was because it was like it was like a 3d
Oh Oh like they had with the gold star
okay it was licensed by Atari Atari okay
that's what makes it it was both sorry
was more okay remember Sears had they
their own watch from Corleone catalog
and stuff like that right even an Atari
joint was more popular so you know give
him bread to sell a joint and people use
their credit cards remember he was able
to get a line of credit which hey yep
gosh alright continue look loan and then
from there my dad came home one day and
it was on the release day of the
Nintendo Entertainment System not home
the nest and we actually had like the
separate duck hunt and the separate no
Super Mario Brothers it wasn't combined
on cartridge and then I bought gyromite
and I'll never forget that I stayed up
like 12 hours a night just playing that
the pens and stuff used to go up at
robot yeah you know what's crazy I never
knew anybody that had robbed I think
maybe they'd give it Lord ha ha ha ha
Rob you know why because that was the
big box that was Brian alibi that was
that was in it to win it
yes that was like the next one yeah a
phone in Wow well my friend had the Sega
Master System and I skipped over that
one because my dad was like oh no no not
Sega you won't want to go with the dead
oh you gotta go
I missed the Master System but I really
like to say a Master System Alex Kidd so
my dad when he got me the Genesis for a
while I love that yeah awesome adventure
did Jesus then I got the Super Nintendo
along as well dad bought me those you
know turbo controller so I could change
Street Fighter turbo you know and then
from there man I never miss like any
system that came out I got the Jaguar I
got the 3do good Corey Jeff you had
cyber wolf at launch yeah you dick okay
okay I gotta respect it I had epic 16 mm
go there now mean you were in the
building together break it was my
all-time favorite failed system
absolutely it was so good yeah like they
was talking the other day and they said
uh what was the best soundtrack for
video games not too many people know
about Lords of thunder and gates of
thunder and I thought they had the best
video game soundtrack and if you go in
then you play those games to this day I
swear that soundtrack it was heavy rock
metal mm-hmm man it fit the game perfect
my first RPG was dungeon explore like my
in the turbo game player
style that get no turbo revolution turbo
penetrated tomographic revolutionized
a lot of things like though was I
believe they were the first with a
illegitimate multi-tap cool right plays
I remember dungeon explorer I remember
motor rotor I remember they had the TV
sports basketball TV sports whatever and
we used it I was a big part of our own
Saturdays like we would really get down
with these multiplayer games so you just
took me back because dungeon Explorer
was a very underrated game was difficult
to but it was like almost like a harder
version of gauntlet you had your
character classes fighter mage and all
that on stuff she held up the clown's
myself on to you the weekends got free
pizza we definitely pulled out the holes
your father set you up to win in life
megaman fire drop right and that was so
hot at the time and my friend came over
he was jealous i had it and my dad heard
him so my dad went out bought it for him
I didn't hear 3d oh was that ever on the
marathon radio I had dad was he a gamer
oh he's just you know he was just making
sure that you had like everything that
you liked and you want it or did he game
with you as well yeah he really wouldn't
play like Nintendo with me he played
some Super Nintendo with me but his big
thing was pinball he'd Clark young and
all tables and he had like the 1776
pinball table in the basement yeah and I
had like the it wasn't even digital I
had like those roll you know things for
the numbers the thing was amazing I
loved that thing and when my mom sold it
I was so mad I wanted to keep that oh I
hate you it that's class because I dunno
you know then it started how much it's
worth
yeah totally cool that is a tremendous
history now this fast-forward and now -
kind of like common time with the big
three so to speak like you know you know
PlayStation Xbox I'm assuming based on
you know based on what you're saying you
have these as well yeah well what was
your progression there as you get closer
to this generation um it was the OG xbox
okay the PlayStation 1 I got those like
that launched the Xbox 360 I didn't get
that out long I've waited on that one
and I actually had a friend that I knew
really well he sent me
be 360 for the first time and I got
hooked on it from there and I bought
like three of them he nice like three
for what purpose in my and then my
daughter played on it too you know and
then we had the three DS is the DS the
2d as man and I like never missed
anything from then on out the only
system I ever missed was the Neo Geo and
the Sega Master System what I'm hearing
is you don't subscribe to tribalism so
tribalism is not a word that you are way
to love it
deprived yourself if you can do it you
know sorry got the gaming system history
down that is dope now I'm also want to
get it to you you know the creation of
the channel and let's start with a one
of my favorites like I said the four
guys work orders shouting lording for
him what kind of led you to that whole
process and getting that going well we
were playing plants for zombies one day
pvz I was meet him assassin and somebody
else and inferno was like you know I
hear a lot of podcasts like are iTunes
and I'd love to do a gaming podcast and
he's like you guys up for it I'm like
yeah man let's do this so he's not for
like a couple days thinking of the name
and I came up with a name for guys with
quarters because I was thinking like
arcade days you know what I mean you
know you walk in the arcade with those
quarters and you drop them mm-hmm and
then from there on out we just evolved
inferno did all the set up and produced
it and I always try to get the guests on
yes
assassin didn't most of our reviews the
original guy that we had with us left us
to play destiny
did we left so we we picked up zebra
Feist nice unfortunately she's got some
stuff going on so she's gonna retire
from the scene for a little bit and now
we're three guys with quarters mm-hmm
nice Oh three guys still there
awesome awesome show like I say huge fan
very nice got really you know advise
everyone that's in the chat you know
please subdue these guys they put out
very high quality content it's
intelligent and um it's just really cool
man I love I love watching your show
always try to catch as much as I can
and then what led you to I saw you also
a panelist of the crossfire parking so
uh what led you to that pocket well I
was I was on Twitter you know of course
like everybody else's these days and I
was seen like Tim dog talk back and
forth with muj and moves talk back and
forth with like you know other people
Mike Ibarra and I was like you know
inferno we should have a presence on
Twitter you can start getting involved
with everyone on Twitter
yep great idea as soon as we did that
next thing I know I'm on crossfire and
your photos on TX are nice all shout out
the TX Ave yeah me too big big podcast
in the community definitely definitely
as much as I can definitely miss TX our
man we're gonna have hopefully have a
one of the TX off that song next week
we'll see fingers crossed on Jake's vote
oh that's cool very very cool history
love that so uh what I want to ask you
is a question I've been asking a lot of
our guests recently so we want to get
into the top five tallien clowns video
game franchises your personal top five
let's go wow you know this is really an
art exactly very hard because I would
have to say Super Mario
okay clown then Super Mario Kart mmm
yeah I can't can't and I cut the car
yeah I would say Donkey Kong Country mm
barrel toads even though it was like not
that many games and hard
yeah and Double Dragon that right there
[Laughter]
so you got cart yeah Barry Oh
Battletoads double drag one dr. country
donkey kong country okay god that's
what's up and last but not least the UH
the science behind the Italian clowns
name I'm nosy oh is it just what it is
is all well um you know back in those
days when everybody had like AOL or mirc
yes sir
my nickname on there was clowns because
I would say jokes that didn't make sense
they'd be like oh you cloud just grew
from there dope I love it first of all
shout out to the artwork or or the icon
feeling we get it with the Lords of
playing this week and bring it right
back two more clowns what have you been
playing this week what you've been but
you've been touched my game Wow
lately I'm playing for tonight because I
got the battle pass and it kind of
hooked me into the tears and the
progression so I'm just stuck on a
fortnight for a bit nice getting your
fortnight on building progress and
getting you suits out and lacking stuff
yeah you know that's what's up Lord
sorrow what have you been playing this
week man um on xbox I had to go back to
state of decay man when I stated the
cable footage got me height and I had
never I never played breakdown like the
new addition lifeline and breakdown they
never really played I just played the
base game so I think I'm I'm playing
breakdown right now the one with the
with the military where you play that
the military personnel so man is just
getting back into that man I'm so amped
for City you guys haven't been watching
like sighs he didn't finally uh-huh I
was an ass you cuz I missed the second
IGN footage can you give me a break the
date breakdown the base building they
broke down the base building
all the stuff that we talked about last
summer they needed to bring up and kind
of get people understanding what this
game is really about um yeah they broke
it down they really broke it down they
broke down some single-player gameplay
as well it just again it they everything
that they promised with that game that
it's just gonna be bigger and more of
what made that game great with the co-op
aspect is there it's like oh it is
fantastic and then with all the God of
War talk I said you know what I gotta
install God of War 3 again so I I never
really finished God of War 3 I went
through I love one and two right and on
three I never got after I got past the
Gaea introduction and in the beginning
of that game which is amazing mm-hmm for
whatever reason I like I just fell off
you know what let me let me play some
God award three get ready forgot war and
so I can talk about the differences and
whatnot right I know why I fell off of
it like I the floating nature of the
gameplay kind of it's just one of those
things like after a while it just became
button mashing I felt like it was what
mask you to me I like the direction
they're going in now but it doesn't take
away from the greatness of the old games
like that intro to God of War three is
off the hook like the grandeur it's
something crazy so yeah man like just
getting ready for God walk and say okay
to build out that's a servant Lord King
when you've been touching this week let
me blow your mind a little because a lot
of times I'm condensing my playlists
doesn't consist of just pub why you know
pub do you get so much love because
literally I have a squad of individuals
that we rotate chat and a little chain
right now so everybody hit those lights
in there please yeah some Assassin's
Creed origin drop date DLC and it yanked
me right back in the game right back in
a little bit again right back in a love
running around Egypt so that's fantastic
I was playing that I played me a little
bit of Halo Wars too
I was doing some cuphead um I jumped
back at recoil cuz somebody I made a
comment about recoil and I always
thought Rico was a very good game a
couple of people who got me to play some
division did that um and also some of
those indie games that popped up I
played that and the burnout paradise
remastered and super lucky still burnout
paradise remastered if you never pay a
burnout paradise or getting your fan of
that genre of game go out and buy it
immediately immediately if you have a 4k
television or X or even if you don't
you're super sample and trust me it is
the essence of the game prettier it's
the game but we did the assets and it's
moving fast and it's like more of what
you love they made your best girlfriend
I forgot to mention that last week I did
I bought like a one-month trial of EI
access so I could get it to the 10 hour
just like this laid it really on the 360
I said let me see what this is about
it's it's a pretty game like I Forza 3
is stole my heart but this is his own
thing and it's in it's hot if you
haven't played it yeah they need to
bring it back they need to bring her not
back absolutely right so that was pretty
much it looking for me I mean spin-up is
so busy now as you know that Lords are
prepping we got packs coming up
three-count up so it's been real big I
haven't gotten a chance to game as much
which just been exclusively ex-con two
of the chosen when I get a chance so
close I defeated two chosen I got one
more left
love the mechanics of the game love how
hard it is on ya now should be finished
with that hopefully by next week I'm
trying to get that done then I can start
getting back into the to the backlog and
knocking stuff out and I will say
there's no man it's hard
I can play next guy and I love rabbits
but it's hard
to go back to rabbits this is so much
it's so deeper your visa is like yeah
that's pretty much what's been going on
me I'm definitely getting ready for
state of decay like a you know saying
law soft said and then obviously you
know see addy you've got to get a little
you know little pirate oil or are are on
exactly oh yeah yeah last week poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question but the recent
return of Microsoft's inside Xbox show
how satisfied are we with the format and
direction of the show the winner at 42%
in a four way poll was the show is way
too long group they need to copy the
deduce which direct format so coming in
at second and 33% was to relax it's a
fine debut group third place at 13% was
the need to copy the presentation of
Sony Group and our fourth place shallow
group we would actually close 12 percent
was the what about those maintenance and
gloves though everybody they say the
show is too long Lord clouds what do you
feel about the whole inside Xbox you
know presentation I don't know I think
it's I think it's good that they're
trying to do something for the fans show
them that you know we're still here
we're not going anywhere I didn't watch
the whole thing cuz I I just don't like
long things that's just my thing but you
know I I think they did a great job the
message is out there that's what it's
for
absolutely absolutely any Lord when
chairman we move on by itself isn't a
problem it's just the content in there
like I don't need all of that you know
back and forth you know dr. Phil this
announcements give me games like do
something can say you know do something
concise so that means that concise means
short fine it
and I feel you that feeling Larry come
out with them gloves every system
products I like I like Larry for what he
certain things that he does certainly
like I can get the the old not cool
uncle by that I like as well but you
know the white glove thing so um yeah we
got our hot off the presses segment
we're gonna jump off right now looks
like a raven from the gaming lords have
been sent to the round so uh god of war
gameplay leaked show so um have we seen
it if we've seen it are impressions what
clans I'm you get a chance to see this
leaked of footage or no I haven't seen
it but you know to be honest it's just
because I was never until the God of War
serious now me gotcha yeah so I was like
oh I'll skip it so you have no interest
of picking up the new money from what
you've seen even previous correct
yeah you don't fanboys coming for you
[Laughter]
will it mate like home I probably like
prior I wasn't I played a couple of them
but I never really know I guess for
whatever reason I kind of missed out on
the one that got water you know saying
for the most part but the new one did
kind of appeal to me when I saw the
trailer and stuff like that so uh Lord
Saab did you get a chance to see the
leaks yeah I actually saw the entire
video before they took it down Cory
Barlow you shut that down quick so yes
going back to what I said about God of
War three like I realized why fell off
of it and for me it was more the combat
thing the combat felt floaty and sort of
button mashing after a while and I know
there is technique to it but in the
middle of battle with a list up
happening it just became easy to sort of
just mask you know square and triangles
going to try and go and grab it and you
you always go see something cool right
the one thing that I see in the new god
of war that they haven't shown yet and I
hope we still there is the sense of
scale and grandeur like like I was
talking about that but the beginning of
God of War 3 when you're climbing Gaia
and you're fighting Poseidon and the
scale of that is amazing it's absolutely
amazing so so far what we've seen him in
the new god of war
that isn't that like even the few bosses
that they've shown don't compare to that
scale right so maybe they're they're
holding some stuff back that we don't
know about um so that's that's the only
thing that I can I can say that you know
I'm not too sure I wish they would I
hope they keep that right um in terms of
the combat anybody who sits there says
that this game does not have DNA rooted
in rice Assassin's Creed origins be
careful be careful sauces and ya know I
know and souls born games his lines of
themselves like anybody doesn't say that
this is not built off of that DNA is
just lying to themselves mmm it's taking
that formula right doing its own thing
with it making it faster making it
brutal making it closer and booter I
think that's for Kratos that's it's sort
of perfect you know when you see these
slow-motion like up close like facial
reactions and he's he's brutal uh and
killed he does officious finished the
kreyòl
I think it suits cradles very well I saw
a little bit of the progression stuff
with the upgrading of the weapons and
stuff like that just a little bit of it
um I think the companion thing with his
son the son seems to be more capable
than like an Ellie and in the Last of Us
runs like AI wise and you you're able to
he doesn't always just operate operate
on his own like you right looks like you
compress the square he could shoot
exactly you go I'm gonna be honest it
the game looks fantastic it's a day one
five for me and he doesn't loot it
doesn't look like a revelation it looks
like it builds upon things that have
come before it including its own DNA to
make something
you but again it fits into that Sony
mode that we've talked about you know
nerd person behind the back action
adventure with art works well works it
works you know I'm not gonna hate on him
for it I'm gonna be there day one you
know let me ask you this quick questions
on loss uh because uh these Twitter
street shot the tea I've gotta check he
goes so hard right there gets good my
question to you is this there's some
pushback in these Twitter streets you
know when you said the rise thing
there's a lot of people to get angry
when they say you how dare you compared
to rise you know an 84 when you look
okay yeah I'll let you said in the last
question decide you go go at the rising
the second thing is there's some there's
a group of gamers that are saying hey
this looks boring to me so what do you
say to those people who like I said it's
mixing rise comparisons or says that
from what they see first the rise
comparisons again you're lying to
yourself if you don't look at those two
games side by side and Caesar
comparisons yes there were things about
rise then were they were simplistic you
know that whole color-coordinated thing
wow like after the first stage they
didn't have you saw most of these most
of the the kill animations and stuff
like it was but the brutality of it you
always felt because you were up close
and personal yeah who's this for
you saw decapitations you saw
amputations up close and personal you
saw the facial expressions on Mario's
face and the people he was killing and
that it just it made it that much more
brutal God of War God of War where were
to get that from where would it get what
other game does that of moving like that
say that also in the parry mechanic the
parry mechanic is is exactly right and
exactly Assassin's Creed origins the
same thing like you know it come on man
it's there it's all they have it like
it's they're like did it am i saying
they specifically looked at in black we
have to copy this no but look at games
are an iterative thing he feel it's very
rare you're gonna have something come
out of nowhere that
there's something completely new that
doesn't build upon something that came
before it let's stop let's yeah oh man
what was the second part of the question
no just to hold that and the you know
the boring narrative people you know
sometimes I don't think so
I mean I saw cradles do things with the
axe like the actual you can throw it you
can trick people with it you can use it
as a straight-up attack you can exactly
exactly so you can do something you can
throw the axe and you can have it stay
inside an enemy why you attacking on an
other enemy and then have it come back
to you you can do things like throw that
an enemy have it stay stuck in him
freeze him walk around him and kick him
into another enemy and then you can do
combos like that and then the same as
all God of War like you can you can um
you can juggle guys throw them up in the
air holding up in the air do different
combo so I don't know about the boring
again we're saying early in the game
maybe I'm assuming you don't have your
entire move set right there so you only
sing a piece of that um I've heard
people argue that the perspective
doesn't lend itself well to an action
game I think again I think for what the
story to trying to tell cradles now I
think having it up close and personal
like behind the bat I think it matters
to what they're trying to do with this
game and we're not gonna be able to see
that further until the game comes out
I'm I'm happy with the direction it's
taking me for me I needed a change
oh the Lord King how you get a chance to
see set footage nope oh you purposely
stay away the gauntlet
I'm going to watch the trailer one time
because I can't have that trail out
there like that and I'm not going back
and I'm not dissecting the trailer now
when it comes to video games if I know
I'm going to buy it there's no need for
me to go look at it or try it there's no
need for me to do that I'm gonna take
the plunge I'm gonna take it back to the
days where we got the Genesis cartridge
and we went off the artwork of the Box
know though okay
they're trapped at work input hashtag
not by god-- whoa there's no need to
voice no nobody has to hear you but poll
talk and there's totally talk it's your
butt oh I don't care if you like it
don't care about my god oh boy the
hashtag you wasn't buying it anyway so
none of the god Awards was your god of
war great red box I'm done with him but
you're playing it I don't care how you
get it I don't care how you I don't care
if you send a [ __ ] down the street to
go get it out of the store for you so
you don't be seen red box at the dump
[Music]
he's like I could talk over old school
he gave you props walking he said that
boxart game selection that's going way
back
a child watch a little bit they would
watch two months you can say but um I
think me and Laura Chi Box were going
back did you see it I said yeah caught a
little bit it I like the new direction I
don't mind it you know I can understand
though from like a god war Paris it had
a may be upset because the direction is
you know so different from what they're
used to but I think I'm sure the Lord
Sam told me to chat like I think it was
needed I think they needed a refreshing
change and um you know I like the ax
thing the only nitpick I'm gonna say and
this is gone people might give me
feelings solve it was a little too foggy
in the back for me I don't know they
were hiding something like no I just
felt I don't know if it was what it was
wanna know if that was a pro it was a
pro the pro felt fireman low fog low low
flow in the background right I didn't
notice it I think I was looking for it I
didn't notice it I'm nitpicking this is
just ultimately picking and I just wish
the arm like the when they were doing it
like the astro fire I'm loving it
commentary fire gotta see how much I
would be annoyed by Atreus talking so
much like come on dad do is that dad dad
like oh I don't know how I'm gonna deal
with that and just create a same boy or
the time boy I do but I don't you say
maybe let's see how repetitive and
annoying that may get and I just wanted
to combat up collect that the executions
fire this room Perry don't um I just
like felt the natural us like
sword-swinging wasn't cool enough I
don't know I felt like they didn't have
as much impact as I may have wanted to
be but again I am nitpicking
I still like the game that's a day one
you know boy will be in the house from
here
there was one gift that made me laugh
though because it goes back to like the
scale of the game right they had a gift
for he's climbing guy or not this big
huge thing right and then they showed it
they showed the part in the in the new
footage where he's looking up at a
little ledge so he's like oh yeah he's
not jumping
yes power of the cloud
this man has correctly predicted the
direction the size and scope of
Microsoft's cloud investment he has
single-handedly did this on numerous
podcast this control the cloud narrative
like nobody does cloud better than
sovereign out here what nobody said they
could talk clout but they don't know the
cloud he can tell you a new cloud tell
him about that black cloud he know about
black cloud this man is back here this
is the glow this is when Barry Bonds
stepped up to the home run do you know
he had a home run
remember when bad boss max it out of the
park you know what was going anyway and
it was over he stood is he flicked the
bat after he looked at it he flicked the
bat he ran past he looked at the picture
this man calling my nose right the funny
thing is I act I wasn't gonna take this
topic right cuz I'm like the safety oh
my god these guys who get pissed at me
with this class them again but they
cause looks like you're gonna take that
topic right what news 5 alright so again
everything that we sort of speculate
about what they're gonna be doing with
the cloud is is actually this is the
first I think the most interesting thing
about this information is that they're
actually coming out and saying it um
that out the TSP I was on TSP earlier
this week talking about Oh a lot from
work what's going on
no I'm not at work oh good good
so don't jump in just cuz you felt that
somebody came for you I came for anybody
that felt that they don't like the game
they don't like the game nobody game
well good I ain't say I didn't like the
game well it looks like a solid game it
just doesn't look like a guard old war
game alright so then don't call the God
of War call it god of Eros and whatever
you want to call it and play it that's
not his name no but is the name that you
want to name it because you own the
company
so if you want to name it god of attic
it is gotta attic
no joy personally when I'm playing it
I'm calling a god a king look learn
attic so I'm assuming you saw the
footage correct yeah I saw the leak
fluid it's already gone now but I saw
what was your impression
well backtrack for you since you missed
that time what was your impressions of
it well it looks fun I you know I
understand where saw was coming from
with the the clothes of head bashing
that you know
krile tech did with with Rhys I'm not
even saying that the gameplay was coffee
doll fries I think that for that part
was you know the counter sister
everything I'm sticking to my number one
skirt man I think Sony is doing the Last
of Us approach and making all their
games last of a style that's what I they
and when it comes to God war they they
can't do your standard you know because
kratos is huge on you know up close and
personal so they can't do really too
much gunplay so they had to make some
kind of melee gotcha now let me let me
counter with this because because
they're going that direction that you
feel like you do you think it's a
mistake I mean considering that last of
what series and all like that's like
huge franchises for them it's not a
mistake but I do feel like when it comes
to this particular game like it's like
sovereign was saying earlier I don't
think it's possible to have big set
pieces like they did in the original
guard wars no not with the kind of
system that they have now mmm
the finances I don't think we're gonna
be fighting you know crate not correct I
don't think we're gonna be fighting you
know well what was Poseidon you fought
beside me and you know I don't know if
that's possible because you literally
fought decided in like five different
locations I mean are the ending boss you
fight of it like six different locations
like remember in in God of War three
when you fought Zeus it was like a
fighter at the very end it was like a
sighs go fight like I don't think that's
because they're always gonna want you to
have that there like when you have that
kind of playing style that you have the
original guard wars you have more
freedom mmm now to forbid it you gotta
play it first he said you don't know
what you talked about I mean an opinion
wait you aren't here why don't you have
an opinion anyway put a file is nice
that's my guy so you don't you just
think because of that engine you don't
think it's possible for them to have so
no it's going to be a guard of war
first off I don't know like in the
original god of warrior let's be real
here it was good but the franchise
picked up on two and three okay mm-hmm I
don't maybe they're gonna do that in
this one we're the first one's gonna be
more about but like I just don't see how
some of the set-piece flights especially
the the puzzles in the original garter
Wars mmm how do you have them in third
part in third person like like and you
know people want to make fun of people
that criticize the game for not jumping
but some of the jumping puzzles were
only possible because you could jump I
mean are we just gonna have a bunch of
you know Final Fantasy Resident Evil
where I got to go to a legit key person
hey to jump off the land and that's what
I'm seeing happening right now
maybe there's some story thing where
he's lost his powers or whatever he's
just a regular dude or what has never
been a regular dude this is the dude
that got killed fought his way up
through hell it killed the hell in the
god of hell and they came out the other
end like it was nothing yes
we got a point attic god no like how did
they narrative Li explain that he can't
do that ok dad and lemon his jumps but
he has to punch the same dude five times
to kill him okay got you topic day today
let's get let's get back to that love
itself with the what's going on with
Microsoft what's the latest really
quickly like again this is the coolest
stuff about this information right at a
pre GDC conference they finally
announced that they have an actual cloud
gaming division dedicated to moving the
Xbox brand beyond consoles in the future
right and I think about the most
interesting thing about this is a they
finally acknowledged it themselves
everything we talked about the cloud and
what they're doing is speculation on our
part has always been right you never
have Phil Spencer or anybody come on be
like it I mean they've talked about the
cloud and respect her to like offloading
you know CPU intensive stuff and see if
thieves and crackdown but again it's
become something of a joke because we
haven't seen it really like to crackdown
hopefully is gonna be at e3 and
hopefully all that multiplayer stuff is
intact and we can actually see this
stuff at work um we're seeing it at work
in some ways with which this stuff would
see if thieves and like the water
physics and stuff like that but this is
all stuff to spin speculation and they
finally came out and said it that's one
too the thing about it is that with all
of the purchases they made coming up to
this with play fab with simply gone with
havoc all the stuff they've been
purchasing up until now to sort of shore
up this this dis initiative now we see
fortnight going to mobile we see pub G
going to mobile simply gone is their
specialty is that getting all this stuff
to work across platforms right
scalability across platforms so the fact
that those things that are so big and
they're gonna continue to be so big
this future that everybody saw a kind of
far away fairly far away mm-hmm I think
we're looking to see it in the next
couple of years man
I think we're with that and that's the
thing like with Phil talking about it
with them being out upfront about it
this stuff we're gonna see this towards
the end of the exes lifecycle and I
think it's gonna be a big part of
whatever the next Xbox is that you think
is huge like to me I don't know on the
hardware side they said we're gonna keep
making consoles and I'm happy about that
because whatever they do whatever
initiatives they do have in the future
I want to experience it on an Xbox
console whatever the case may be the
question is how does this stuff
translate to them trying to take over
the world and beyond Nintendo and beyond
Playstation right what is that gonna be
so now that we've got all this
informations come out looks like
Microsoft is doubling down on their
cloud division what is it a stature
actually no my boy ocarina child Ramesh
good dude yeah I believe he's the one in
the trailer that was like it's a monster
but really cool guy very intelligent on
me I think he's heading it and according
to on him he said that Phil kind of
approached him and said that you know
they really want to get involved and
double down in that space we know about
the I'm acquiring havoc what is it
simply gone and played all these little
bold kind of cloud gaming acquisitions
and stuff like that so now that you're
hearing this kind of stuff clowns like
what what do you think about it will you
take Microsoft's headed do you think
it's a good idea what's your overall
feelings on it well about four years ago
for gasma quarters and well I you see
it's just so much cheaper for
corporations to do this because they can
make diskless Hardware right which would
drop the cost
it gives them better DRM over their
content you're not good question is I
hate to interrupt you for a second like
how much would it drop the cause though
would it be worth
dropping cost like to have a backlash
when it comes to discus media they're
gearing us up towards that way now I
don't know if there will be a backlash
there my pikas are still some people
that like physical disks so they could
always make an addon like Sega Genesis
did with the Sega CD that's possibility
but if I'm at imagine producing in bulk
though the discounts corporations would
get making this this was mm okay
my future soon and um just like also in
general as far as like besides the
diskless stuff doc what about them like
the whole like we know crackdown as a
title that you know very important
reference to like ingame offloading
stuff like do you see that happening you
know like stuff like look like the huh
crackdown suppose supposedly be doing
the multiplayer in the instruction in
stuff like that yeah I mean I can see it
and everything in the cloud gotcha
so this could be real is what you say
look like this this is there's not a
fable this is because that we've been
hearing this talk before right it'll
prior to that it was like yeah yeah
outside of titanfall we didn't really
yeah but you that it's you know in the
end it's cheaper for corporations right
you gotta understand this part when
you're rich you're not going out handing
out money you know what it is to be poor
so you're holding onto that money as
much as possible all right you're trying
to get more to ensure that you will end
up like the poor so to
considered affected think this is why
digital isn't a 999 this is now this is
why you can't get super lucky tail in
fur instead of $29.99 its $9.99 that
would be awesome for you right that data
be them kicking you back something right
not gonna happen it's always going to be
the premium price and I know you saying
the brick-and-mortar stores is the
reason why it's like that and when we go
completely digital we're gonna kick
these brick-and-mortar stores either way
yeah at the same 5995 because they're
going to tell you that well monopoly
exactly Microsoft has shown you like
clowns said they're moving in that
direction like sovereign said this is
the wave of the future but they have to
or set their course with charging you
like a premium dollar is that premium
dollar 3995 it could be we see a part
where we lost a chunk of let's say $15
is that giving back could be but then
what was the price of the system to make
you know it's always gonna weigh left or
right it's not in the benefit of the
consumer
even though Microsoft has shown they're
a little bit more consumer friendly than
others don't get it wrong ban the
business to make a buck nice lose the
dollar absolutely let me ask you this
cuz a face 23 bkn wanna chat as he says
he thinks mark stops going in this
direction because they can't compete in
traditional sense with Sony so it's
better to put their stuff on other
platforms to get you know some of the
stuff like Nintendo PC and Sony tablets
what what do you guys feel about that
cuz we're also hearing stuff in the
streets like could this mean what they
say America 25 million in America their
base is in Europe the European base
because they got a foothold over there
they made strategic moves to get a
foothold there before Microsoft launched
in those countries and Microsoft has
traditionally we
in those countries stop with the
tribalism Xbox right I think every all
Xbox foreheads like I think we have to
acknowledge the fact that just the Xbox
brand doesn't have to pull that
PlayStation or Nintendo has on a globe
just because it doesn't have the pool
doesn't mean it's not competing no
people be acting like of Microsoft ain't
rippling they sells they're not
competing at all that's what it means to
us but when they're in that boardroom it
has a totally different meaning right
mm-hmm
when you're in that boardroom and they
say they made four point five billion
dollars in profit this job don't
understand that what do you thought they
always want more the border is not happy
what go on why's promoted like there was
any truth whatsoever to Microsoft
wanting to divest itself from Xbox right
for the wedding there said all right I'm
good let me keep making my consoles and
I'm gonna give you a way that we're
gonna take over everything we're gonna
be everywhere and they're like okay
because that's what Microsoft cares
about right hmm no matter how well Xbox
is doing Microsoft cares about
Microsoft's bottom they don't and it
doesn't matter how well anybody's doing
that's the overall direction in this is
a gaming industry it's flying but okay
but the thing about it is if they know
that on a global scale in the console
space they can't they don't have the
same recognition and pull that
PlayStation or Nintendo does and what do
you do you open that up right you open
that up and you go to other places right
now the question people have is does
that mean they're gonna try to put their
stuff on PlayStation long in fact a
rumor in the street if they're not doing
that like they're [ __ ] people who
think that's [ __ ] like I'm sorry
like people who I'm not
done one thing besides minecraft it make
me think anything remotely is closer
than putting other stuff on a platform I
hear what you going Lord addict the only
comma I would say and again I agree with
you so far there's not shown that way
but a lot of people again in this
console war they look at one wrong but I
will be highlighting them on play
anywhere right they look at stuff like
um you know obviously the game I have a
counter to that to foil for it
what other bread did the Sony the Sony
Nintendo or a platform on that brand can
they post stuff to can they post stuff
to another platform like Windows 10 and
make money off of it do they own
something like Windows 10 like hey can
they can the other two even do remotely
anything like that no they can't like
that I get I guarantee you a PlayStation
I was poppin that [ __ ] would already be
on PlayStation now everything would be
it is not so they can't do it they don't
have the infrastructure on those other
platforms just to be pop it and be like
this is mine because they don't well the
problem with the the guy cart thing
ended up being like a lot of people just
didn't like the latency it just wasn't
well-received right it wasn't it was one
of those things that you know maybe at
the time when it's launched like as we
know now coming 5g and all that stuff's
coming you know faster speeds and stuff
like that coming so maybe cloud
infrastructure becomes more viable you
know I'm saying but this is something
that Microsoft is gonna do they're
basically foreshadowing I'm saying it's
for as far as it's something the entire
industry is trying to get to but
Microsoft has the infrastructure
probably five to ten years before anyone
else so the question is and I'm spoiling
my damn poll question I didn't show what
anyway the question is oh you know
because of this you know what do we the
Lord stink does does Microsoft lose
their commitment to the console space or
do they still or is this just something
that no people are overreacting this is
just something they're doing in addition
the console space I think they recognize
the strengths of giving people options
or
the only ones that give their consumers
this many options right so they
recognize that at the same time at the
same time in the long term right they're
not gonna tell us right now we've dead
in the console they're not gonna say
that right so in the long term if they
feel is more profitable for them to be
an app somewhere rather than invest in
their own hardware they're gonna go back
on this promise and we're not gonna see
a console I'm telling you and it's gonna
be what its gonna be what Microsoft has
a whole wants because the thing about it
is I agree with that if they if at some
point they decide you know what we need
to be on these other platforms just
forget about this because the thing is
nor Sony or Playstation neither one of
them isn't gonna agree to have an Xbox
app or whatever on their platform with
you still having heart your own hardware
they're not gonna agree that they're not
gonna play ball even even if they go to
app I highly doubt to go to another
console I just don't know what literally
like that it maybe if like I just don't
see that happening like because I'm
telling you like let me give you because
I was saying I feel you going but what
surprised me is in this article wisdom
when they were talking about Rainbow six
siege how that's using Microsoft Azure
servers on PlayStation I didn't even
know that that kind of bugged me out
right that's like that's something
different than putting your boosters on
the car no I completely that's a
completely different service than the
Xbox brand like I'm told you have to
contact Microsoft's as earlier whatever
the whatever they're called but you get
what I'm saying like at the end of the
day like there's just no way like
because let's be real here like
Microsoft will be like whoa
you know we'll make more money but
what's gonna eventually happen to two to
three years after Microsoft goes apps
mm-hmm
Sony and atender are gonna go they were
gonna have this same conversation but
it's going to be services and not and
not platforms gotcha nor clowns what do
you feel how are you going to compete
with the other platforms when you
your apps on their apps that leaves no
sense Windows 10 is everywhere
there you go it's not competing it's
about it's about winning another way
you're not gonna compete directly
anymore that's the and that's a worry
with this yeah they try to compete with
steam all the time but I don't
understand why you're saying they're not
trying to compete they're eventually
gonna buy steam because it's you know
the de facto for PC gaming but Windows
10 is in almost every home right
everybody who owns a computer whether
you're in Europe right and that's
because it's that that's their platform
is not a Sony platform they make sense
to put on there like like I'll get that
but that that's the clouds finish future
once people are more comfortable with
Windows hadn't been everywhere and
Microsoft being a ruler we could
probably even see TVs with Windows 10
built-in and an Xbox app and that's the
thing that's what they say like it can
happen because that what the point where
it becomes financially the smart thing
to do rather than continuing to build
your own stuff and you can have your
hands and everywhere that's what they
want that is the multi smart things
abundant that you could use that same
logic right now why if they [ __ ] on
there right now that's the business move
right now why haven't they done it if
that's the superior business mean they
have to do it it's not there yet
it's not completely there you can think
about it right if you have let's say
they do the Xbox F thing right and they
still have their own hardware right um
but let's say only on xbox can you
actually download the games and play
them locally everywhere else though it's
off the cloud completely right there's
no there's no software download directly
to that device right now you're talking
about a quality issue right you can't
you cannot have your name out there on
another device with an inferior product
than what you have at home because at
that point you're killing your name
right so you have to get the tech to a
point where it's the same across
everything and this is what they're
starting to do with pub G online
with fortnight online and having it
across all of these different platforms
you it's not there yet they're talking
about it because they know it's a
concrete thing they're gonna do right
it's not there yet though they're making
the moves to put it in place and make
everybody dependent on them young
interesting and what about this whole
narrative about the two billion gamers
you know what I'm saying like you know
across the board they want to reach in
that space so you think this is the play
like no interesting everywhere they want
to be everywhere because they know
specifically in the console space on a
worldwide scale they cannot compete with
the PlayStation or Nintendo name it just
it'll never be at that top and as a
Microsoft fan as the Xbox fan we have to
acknowledge that if we look at the 360
generation right the 360 was their
chance to do it and simply by the fact
that PlayStation was able to come back
at the end of that endpoint in a shows
you like king is said in the past right
Microsoft is Xbox is that is the brand
that we have here it's not the brand
that a lot of people want it to be here
like if you have you tell me right now
listen I'm gonna put you in a time
machine I'm gonna take you back to 1999
in 1999 Sega doesn't fail and the
Dreamcast is a success but oh you have
the option to have Microsoft jump into
the game into the gaming space I'm gonna
take Sega's order for them to go
third-party like that they would have to
completely fail like and I mean come
like not like the way you think
completely fell like they're like we
just can't do this I don't think that's
gonna be a point because they're always
gonna have that that support maybe from
the American audience and some of the
European audience like I don't think
they'll get to the point where they need
to go third-party I don't think that's
thing it's not a neat thing again it's
about how much they're gonna look at how
much money they make here and how much
money they make there and they're gonna
go the route that makes them the most
money and again it's and if those
decisions my point is then why never
mind I'm not gonna want you to go cuz
you're making you're making you know I'm
gonna say no don't give up what you're
saying is a lot of people
they that people are overreacting right
oh that there is there is this is
something that just digits
future-proofing but there is never a
chance of them getting out of the
conference because they're making money
they're successful and it's an
overreaction you know and I think that's
what kind of addict is getting off if
you double down I agree except for the
fact that they literally made like four
point some billion dollars in profit
from the earth because I want them to
continue in the console space and they
said they said as much as they're gonna
continue that I'm just saying in the
long term if it becomes viable to
deliver the same experiences quality
experiences as you would get locally
everywhere else but that that can
literally be with any brand like Sony
can literally have the same thought
process when they go out everyone can
have the same thought process look like
you said to do said plan that's what I
said we're all in agreement if you
really look at what we're saying I'm
just saying that that thought process
could be used on all of the platform
owners not just my course all right but
all of the platform owners are not in
the position of Microsoft to actually
make that a reality they don't have the
infrastructure to make that a reality
we've seen with Sony Y thing they didn't
didn't anything anything they would get
come to Microsoft for that
infrastructure they would come to them
for that for that expertise Lord King
we've been cutting out what's most where
you feel not checking us man letting us
know that we can get a calm down
everything both of you have been saying
I've been green with clowns um I've been
agreeing with sovereign and I've been
agreeing with adding we're at a fork in
the road where if they're hedging their
best and they shows you where they're
hedging their bets they're hedging their
bets into this cloud now where does that
cloud take us everybody is so mystified
by where it's going to take us it's
going to take us to where they want to
be
they want to leave Annette's Netflix
they want to be the next app they want
to be formless like water
you understand that way it can go
anywhere at any time when you pick up
your phone and you have the same exact
experience on yo 800 $900 phone that is
more than your Xbox price there is data
get in and there is like as much as I
hate to say this like as of right now
Microsoft couldn't even do that if they
wanted so even if they had the
infrastructure tomorrow because you
can't put first off I don't think
something like game paths in the long
run is going to be something that's
going to be around because I guarantee
you in the next five years all these
third parties that you're supporting
gamepads going to pull out of supporting
game passionately make their own game
pass that's a bold one before you know
you got people like Ubisoft
maybe not Sega because I don't know Sega
would Wanda maintain that infrastructure
but then Microsoft's got to rely on
their first parties and as of right now
they showed me they have no real what's
warm licking force no no like the only
grow game that they have right now that
they could sell on us on a game pass to
see it these right like as people in the
next five years would people subscribe
to a whole service for one game like
maybe five games so you don't believe in
it the fills with a dub version with the
doubling down on the first fight night
things are gonna be in position it's
just I I guarantee you guys that I mean
it's already rumored that Square Enix is
doing Inc there's rumor that that uh
Warner Brothers is doing it I mean like
it's that this is this is a failed
strategy this is a this is of not this
is a strategy that you don't see
long-term working with with game pass
but if that's the case of this failed
strategies and does their banking a lot
on this right we know that they're
banking a lot of the sort of if these
things don't pan out then what happens
it's an option just let me just say this
Xbox is the only system that gives you
choice mm-hmm okay
you really have absolute choice Sony
calls off the whole idea of EA access
Microsoft embraced the idea of EA access
I said before when Phil had that steam
shirt on a voucher that I thought steam
would be on Xbox it made proper sense
right I feel they are open to all ideas
and they are trying to view it in that
prism that if we're open we won't close
ourselves off to certain ideas Nintendo
is a complete traditionalist in the way
that they deal with their corporate
business not their gaming their gaming
division they're open-minded with
wherever they're gonna take the new
controller wherever they're gonna take
the system right if they use the same
openness with business strategy then
Nintendo would have a whole lot more
third party interaction and stuff like
that we're seeing that happen now all
right remember I said with the dinosaurs
dying the Younger are coming up and it's
changing the philosophy and the DNA
inside Nintendo give it a couple of more
years Nintendo will be like a Sony and a
Microsoft Microsoft is a little bit more
progressive is because of our European
Oh
DNA our Western DNA we're more inviting
we're multicultural so we're doing
things in a different fashion
all right Sony is a traditional Japanese
company whereas fundamentally they're
sound in this they do hardware and
they're adding the games
so when sovereign says stuff a cut and
paste they see a formula that works
they're going to work with them when
Attucks says our God of War looks like
of the Last of Us type of thing this is
what they do because they know it's
successful okay Microsoft will branch
out and try to do unconventional things
sometimes it fails sometimes it doesn't
sometimes they succeeded but we have to
embrace that
they all will be apps PlayStation tried
it with that now app because every
television from Chevy tell me with it
like clowns net launched on every
television Microsoft doesn't have a
television division every day when I
have game past so know that they want to
get to that space they will have to
partner with a Samsung like they
partnered in the past or a big brand to
bring that to you but don't think for
one instant that they don't want to be
the next Netflix or next Amazon yeah
that's where the box is that agrees
Macri would you shout out to us and with
tobert into charity I've got you know in
reference to what we were talking about
earlier when I was talking about their
feeling is that the market can support
you know a hundred different
subscription services like a gamepad and
Sam told me a good point he was just
like that's why Warner Brothers actually
joined with them EA
Origin access so that is true if
financial might not be in place for that
that's why I just want to jump into it
cuz I know this is a great topic there's
actually cking it was a good topic
[Applause]
knowledge when it comes to things that I
don't know do you know I don't know it
so it when he knows it and he puts it
out there that's my brother and I'm
rawness to be honest this is the most
in-depth conversation we've had about
we've had about it remember what I
treated it out I said we got
confirmation no yo ass is staring at the
ball good points man also too but I
wanted to get with this because on the
verge article and the game industry
bears article when they were talking
about that whole two billion you know
and by 2020 that's how Microsoft mean
you know envisions how many people
playing video games
you know they want to reach them all
they think the parameters are changing
so like the way they looking at it right
now according to this article you know
it's like you know right now there's a
hundred and forty four million minecraft
owners right in Microsoft's eyes even
the ones that are on PlayStation 4 is an
Xbox customer yeah they said anyone who
plans to play see of these on Windows 10
in Microsoft's eyes is an Xbox customer
you know I'm saying anybody who does are
streaming or mixer football would pop G
ain't looking at it Xbox customer so
it's just I think the rules are changing
you know I'm saying in how they envision
themselves it down the road I agree with
attic though and I don't see them
abandoning the console space it's still
successful for them ok I guess the irony
one isn't you joint until they abandon
the console infrastructure and they
abandoned like until they formally
announce that they even kid like I just
don't see go for Monaco see what I when
it comes to that it's like it'd be
different if you know they had a really
hard time on the orig
the original Xbox wasn't even a huge
success but it was still successful
considering it was our first console the
360 did phenomenally well the entire
generation but started dying down at the
end I mean the Xbox one is is still
ahead of the tert card when it comes to
the 360 and the 360 was a huge success
so like I just don't see the trends for
them to have to do it what they are
doing it no matter we can't again and
it'll jumped out in this city no I'm
talking about go I'm talking about going
to a going third party with the red
thing there are things happening putting
their app on competing platforms oh ok
so we talk about two different things
the only way that would happen is if
they stopped making consoles that and AD
that's the thing like me because again I
don't think either Sony or a Nintendo
plays ball they like no hell no no no
on our system you're not gonna have a
product you're gonna have the Xbox brand
I mean that's that's overall go they're
tired of paying for what it cost them to
make the console like they want to get
rid of that yeah so you think they want
to get out the console space
all right I've never said no my argument
my argument was is they not going to
start putting their stuff on the
platform on other platforms like it
would have to be something drastic
because even if they do that like I just
don't see it like they're gonna keep it
on their platforms regardless what some
salty yeah I mean listen to me I think
this thing is future proofing I think
the brand isn't going nowhere I think
they're fine right now they're healthy
right now I just think that this is a
future-proof move that this could be
shot the fonz interchange is actually
saying exactly what I'm saying like 10
years from now 20 years from now down
the road is to me this is just a future
proofing hedging your bets literally
this might not even be in my lifetime
this could be this could be 10 to 30
years from now just depends on in order
for this future to happen internet has
to drastically improve how it is
especially in the United States but that
is improving
that's all trying to tell you later that
isn't for 5 G's coming infrastructure is
employment we know structure and then we
get stuff on the vice versa that helps
that hurts it from growing all I'm
saying is at this point it's gone right
now we can't see it because right now
infrastructure is not in place right so
I I hear what you're saying
all I'm saying is I've 10 years from now
that could change things change now
think about us now on fiber-optic and
think about here's the thing though
about something like that
here's the thing though is the average
is the the consumer that you guys think
that they're trying to attack are they
all
gonna pay for something like fiber-optic
because this biro it's it's not going to
take something like I pay a hundred and
twenty dollars a month for it not
confined space you're thinking about
right now yeah countries where I think
they get faster internet for free
through fiber yep that's why I say
America like we have so many
infrastructure that's put in place to go
on the internet say whatever it is that
they're doing they're gonna if you're a
fan of Microsoft you're a fan of Xbox
get ready cuz you we're gonna take it on
the chin because then trailblazing again
if you're a staunch supporter or a
defender of whatever they do once again
they're at the forefront of this and
they're gonna take it on the chin
because up until it becomes viable
across the board the Nintendo and
PlayStation gonna act like this stuff is
not relevant and it's like no we're not
going that route we're not going that
route and we're not going to route and
so ultimately they will go that route
infrastructure with the I mean look what
that was foolish when Microsoft didn't
look cool look what happen attend oh
when they didn't think gonna cartridges
was a big deal like they're like we need
to stay here and then they ended up
they're doing the same thing the next
generation you see what's gonna happen
this is this is good y'all gonna love
the poll questions we gonna move on we
got like kings today we killed this
thing to death but it was a great
discussion we had to jump on it so I'm
gonna get the next topic I'll breeze
through it as fast as I possibly can arm
so we know Microsoft has announced that
this is gonna be the biggest III showing
ever they've moved that's funny
they move their whole thing to a new
venue so rest in peace to the Galen
Center memories get an incentive
amazing breakfast is used to have free
you know Phil used to come out yes sir
now they're gonna have the same thing
it's just gonna be bigger
he's not gonna have to actually come out
into the gym he's gonna just be asking
like the little penny and thing and be
like so ya better go to the Microsoft
theater you know me so it's gonna be
this whole huge new venue and what I
thought was interesting is also is that
they're actually still keeping Sunday as
their day as we know last year they
debut that because they said they wanted
to give enough time to the Scorpio you
know and I'm giving it today but they're
still sticking with the Sunday having
their briefing the marks are briefing on
June 10th to allow more fans and
partners to do that and they're not on
actually they're not abandoning the Los
Angeles Convention Center they're still
gonna have a what you call it a mixer
booth there you can play streaming in
Iraq you know what kind of things so
they're doing this they're still saying
they're doing this in collaboration with
the ESA and yeah I just wanted to bring
this to the Lord you know what do we
feel about it also on in reference to
the rhetoric obviously biggest III ever
you know how do you feel about that you
know do we how important is this e3 for
them and also do we think it will
deliver so let's start with Lord clowns
the new venue they're updated presents
you know what do we feel about that and
the biggest III ever from Microsoft well
I think that the venue move is just
because it's probably cheaper for them
since you know they already sponsoring
as far as the biggest III presence ever
I have no idea it could be more about
the cloud or their deals with partners
maybe what they're looking forward to in
the future so hopefully you know they
can elaborate on some of this cloud
stuff and where they're headed mm-hmm
now on what about the what about like
Sunday like um retaining the Sunday data
as opposed to going back how you used to
be to the Monday they would go first in
the morning or whatever it would be in
this on you would come after do you
think that's a good move yeah I think
it's a fine move maybe they just wanna
say what they gotta say before somebody
leaks it the the the the and the
rhetoric of behind like biggest III ever
you think it's hyperbole do you think
that they think the chest is out the day
they're coming with the goods what do
you think
I think it's you know I hate to say this
I just think it's marketing hype
absolutely but I do think that the fans
are probably to me excited it as always
you know we were excited about the X so
it's gonna be something exciting for us
fans in general absolutely all right
Lord addict what do you feel about all
this the new venue being on me in a gala
center no more man what do you what do
you feel now at the end of the day it's
like it just depends like first off I I
completely understand degree of clowns I
think if anything you know could be a
multiple masks different things that
they're trying to do they could try to
be promoting the the building itself by
doing a stage there at the biggest
gaming convention I mean because they
said in the actual interview when they
were showing the building that they're
trying to you know have that one of the
biggest places that you know events
could happen you they actually mentioned
you I've seen stuff by name so it's you
know it's like I said they could be
trying to you know cross market that
between different between different
brands it's like they probably get a
massive discount for being there so you
know that's definitely one of the things
I could see but you know like it doesn't
matter if it's bigger if they don't
actually use it like let's say that
instead of like Forza horizon fourths
that I've been one car they have for
around what about you know in the I was
more interested I was more interested in
how he's like they really went on and on
about fan fest be part of that heart of
a building like they mentioned fan fest
part of that building so like I don't
know like does that mean they're gonna
because one of the reasons that I was
told last year III the reason that you
know they limit how many people's in fan
fest is because of the Galen Center
because every person that gets in fan
fest that they let them go to the
conference so like are they going to do
more of like a fan recognition thing
where they let more fans
are they gonna have you know where they
light a little bit more fans in to
actually see the conference if because
Sony does the same thing they don't do a
fan fest but they might like the first
couple hundred people and in the back
yeah it's gonna be interesting to fan
fest this yeah I would agree yeah I
would agree my I think people need a
yeah finishing a national question I
think people need to start like tripping
like acting like because they got a
bigger venue that that's gonna mean
anything like they can literally just
use the the that that one room that we
saw like who cares how big the building
is if they use one massive room and
that's all yeah my question to you is
that mean uh it was a some some early
information that had leaked like a month
ago there was a big booth gate
controversy you know we jumped out in
front of it cuz we saw the UH admission
force-placed paying it didn't look so
good for Maxo so it turns out that that
was not really the case and that you
know the venue's big does that make you
feel better that Microsoft has more to
show I know me and you may have been a
little guilty of being a little nervous
about the floor plan that we saw that
got leaked that was good you know showed
up to people on Twitter because uh you
know Tim dog Lord Sam dog he had a a
poll that asked what was the most
overreaction when it comes to Microsoft
and that was one of the options and like
I definitely understand you know some
people's opinion on how that was an
overreaction but like me personally I
don't think that was an overreaction
like if you have the booth size half the
size as literally the brew size was this
was half the size is Sony's prt
like that was not an early look that was
no that wasn't an ovary actually if you
don't have the space to show me games
you I don't think you're having games
like I don't think how that's an
overreaction you know that that's the
other here there but it's whatever like
they could do stuff there like it
doesn't really bother me no doubt Lord
sauce what's your family yeah I mean I
think if you have if you own the venue
use the venue like it's not it's not
it's across the street if it were far
away I can see why
I you know the the choice to use the
Galen Center makes sense but you're
across the street you're in the middle
of everything and it's and it's your
building use it to your advantage so
yeah I'm glad they're finally doing that
and I added kind of took my point with
the fan fest thing um fan fest you know
is usually what anywhere from 500 maybe
to 700 people you know they're all about
engagement and engaging with you know
getting the fans like it's like 500
people but they need more if they have
to put more than 500 people and it's
like what can we fit these people in
this in this conference man like
remember King Oh
like we got into Fan Fest and they let
so many people win because of that giant
fiasco that happened last year we were
actually in the bleachers to the right
of the fit of the because they had no
they didn't have enough room for
everyone because only all the entire fan
fests can fit on the floor where they're
supposed to do yeah but they actually
had way more people than they thought
they were going to have because they
just like it was such a fiasco with it
because not only did that website go
down once it went down twice
[Laughter]
people like you know saying well I don't
you know I think people were
exaggerating by getting mad at that it's
like no it's like like look I can I can
assure you that there is a lot of people
the Mon cuz they didn't announce it for
like three or four hours after that I
happened yes because remember they said
well we're not having the later drawings
in 30 hours and then they delight it
again and then they delayed it again we
do then they explain and then they
explain what happened and I was like
look like I completely understand people
like well why did people go out
immediately after you with a one fan
fest and go by their plane tickets and
hotel well you are they gonna wait if
you got the money did you have the
surface ticket do you expect people to
lights like the day before when it's
like fifteen hundred dollars to have
quote a coach to go from you today like
that make no sense to me Microsoft knew
that they needed to do something and
like they not always did
give people tickets they were actually
lighting a lot of people in that got cuz
the first time if it messed up you got
the the III ticket the second time it
messed up they were just lighting you
have the fan fest ik yeah absolutely
solve you has something I was gonna give
it to King and I think that's that's the
thing like even if let's say they let a
thousand people 1200 people whatever in
the fan fest and not everybody can get
into the actual international press
conference the fact that you have all
the fans there you can still have it you
know on closed-circuit for the people
that you don't fit in into the actual
you know press conference they feel that
part of it it's still located in one
centralized place and the festivities
continue it's not like you're separating
people's I just think they want all the
Xbox loves to be in one place and it
doesn't make sense
another thing is that being their own
building they can start prepping now
they can start rehearsing now because
I'm not great at pronouncing stuff and
they're not great at the stuff that you
know Sony and Nintendo are good at so it
gives them that from now get it right a
big thing I think that one of the
biggest highlights is don't expect a lot
of stuff to get leaked this year because
I hope not every year at the Galen
Center when they do those rehearses for
the host and I literally how they're
always because Microsoft is gonna have
this press conference we're only like
because you you can if you're going to a
third-party event like that we're not
your building you can't really do a
whole whole lot I don't know if they own
that building or not but they have more
say on what's going on in that building
then they do the Galen Center I would
agree it's really hard to keep stuff
that wraps because you can't stop
certain people that work for that
building and if that person knows
relatively anything he can do serious
damage like imagine that the Microsoft
if Master Chief collection wasn't leaked
mmm-hmm no it's a good point because I
remember prior to the show like someone
leaked almost Phil's whole spiel about
know what he was gonna announce and I'm
just like
you know I mean and if it gets leaked
this year I guarantee you Microsoft is
going to know exactly who did it because
they had control over who was there
Sunday it's the internet existed just
this whole we have a big Center like
boom when the plans leak before people
standing on podiums you got a small
space they gonna be selling down ladies
out that's why in the grand scheme of
things we don't we're not privy to
really what's going on in these
companies Thanks okay so all you doing
the speculation and gossip Boston in the
corner playing a fool and then it comes
out that you're wrong now I don't ever
see nobody backtrack on they wronged
anybody put a hand up and say yo they
got me you know unless you wonder force
them to care for it because you second
King David is not that man this man made
a video was like I was wrong every
occasion he's been wrong on this
a man held accountable for your your
words your word is your bond if you have
if you stand for nothing if you stand
for nothing you fall for everything all
right so I want you to understand they
got this big Center and they're doing
fan fests and they're showing these
games and they say this is gonna be the
biggest ever yes it's a bigger building
yes they're gonna have more people yes
they're gonna probably show more games
yes they're gonna have more interaction
so yes is it the biggest thing for them
yes no it's a yes so it's no rhetoric is
it as the hyperbole it's not hyperbole
like he said if there's two cars it's
three cars if it's a true pirates
dancing it's 12 pirates dancing okay the
part that never made sense to me when it
comes stuff like that is like I
understand you know people get tired of
you know I see a lot of people go on air
and green bird a lot over you know some
of the remarks he makes when he hikes
the brands it's like biggest Microsoft
thing ever like you have to understand
that's just part of the marketing spiel
perspective it's like perspective
exactly helpful Spencer and now it's you
know on he what happened was someone
asked them they were joke and they say
can you link all of e3 right now he said
I could but then I III you people would
say there was no new news we are at a
point now I love all the information
that came out about this stuff I love it
all I love the space of Nintendo
Nintendo had a space that was beautiful
this takes crowded last year yeah it was
insane but this this opens up one of our
biggest concerns
face if you've never been to e3 last
year you understood that you were
shoulder to shoulder rubbing elbows with
individuals that you wouldn't wanna
sometimes and it was just too crowded
and you didn't get the enjoyment that
you needed one company took it out of
that cramped space and said okay we're
gonna give you this space here but we
can make it less cramped so it could be
more enjoyable hell is that bad not bad
at all just like I said a lot of people
like you said looking just have to eat
their words you know they didn't want to
fall on this so yeah we gotta move on
but um yeah I just I agree with all the
Lords everything you know what I'm
saying in reference of marketing you
know what I'm saying
I'm loving that they controlling their
own space I think that um you know for
the most part this is a very positive
thing I actually love the fact that they
remaining on Sunday I think that's a
great idea I think this is something
they should enjoy or you think it's
weird why I feel like last year the
reason they did that was because of the
ex feel like I don't know it's weird
that they don't go back to their Sunday
night mm-hmm shout out the braaap you
see will they have a band again the
reason that probably benefits and is
probably not having a whole day to
themselves because at the end of the day
if it des analysis Elder Scrolls 6 this
year 83 nothing Microsoft announced is
going to be but at the end of the day I
don't think it's necessary on having a
day to themselves I think so I being the
first event to knock off to start you
3-wood I still think it's to having it
in yourself is huge I think that 24-hour
news cycle you're in the mind chair for
a while because prior to that they would
jump and they would only have the head
for a couple of hours when they want him
one day until Sony comes right behind
and then the other thing I did like is
Sony had the Billy to counter right away
you know they really had the counter
right away fine I hate what you're
saying I completely understand
all I'm saying is 24-hour cycle to have
the media to yourself I like you
shouldn't you shouldn't really like when
it comes to stuff like that I know
that's probably something that they do
think about you know just me talking
from a competitive standpoint but I
agree as a company you've got to do you
put out your message and be done you
know I'm saying that's cool you guys
gonna be interested see what happens you
know how did the Fantas like that it's
in the venue big exciting things I think
that's kind of hyperbole
they just got to bring the games they've
got the bringing in and I've told they
got to this year is to hold the moat
absolutely I've told Lord King this on
and found no Phil it's his xbox only
begotten Son our Lord and Savior his
Lord said i judge Phil I'm not I mean
he's got the box he's won he's in
position he's at the Microsoft round
table and I feel like he's been here
long enough for at least CGI cutscenes
for games he put in development listen
and even if things are not fin I think
they even have to break protocol even if
things they don't like to show things
that are not finished all the way yet
they have to give us a couple of you
know teasers and that's what I said CJ
yeah like even if there's no CGI I'd say
something something they have to get
their base galvanized that this is this
is the year you know me think about it
this is the first year besides crackdown
maybe they'll show something about state
of decay but they really they didn't
announce anything big last year so it's
not gonna be at this year's e3 besides
maybe anthem
what else could fill up that that time
for Xbox only begotten Son that's your
beer
just say I'm just saying his great name
my profile they will be all talk he
ain't doing nothing after the show this
III is going to be a movie right it's
going to be a movie
shout out to midnight he is the complete
photographer 100% editor 100% photograph
genius that's going to be behind the
production of a movie there's going to
be a movie and if I feel it this way I
feel the goosebumps in this manner and
I'm going to spawn this big on trust me
when I tell you this attic III is going
to be so big for the iron Lords podcast
and fulfill spencer himself because
he'll got a big haul
he got ahold he said i'm a separate
myself from these individual because
they are not on my level
I took sunday sunday is my day looking
at it and I'm not seeing it for what it
is he said he didn't like certain things
and he's changing it when a boss doesn't
like things he does it through actions
he removes your rhetoric you told you
that y'all said yeah I wasn't powerful
enough shut up your boxes weaker never
get eggs we disciple they didn't like
how they can we just come right behind
like Laura Cognito said they come right
behind you say something to come right
behind it take it away you don't like
that we want that 24-hour cycle what
we're gonna do take Sunday that's giving
you goosebumps
the heat of the Sun and I'm telling you
open your window let that Sun and get
out they brought 4k - you love 4k in
your face they collected do something
else that's gonna be amazing
and then you're gonna say well but he
had the games but can he deliver shut up
you're at a point right now where you're
running out of excuses and you're
bending in me baby baby deepness Xbox
we've got it we got to repay it
you got it we're gonna move up on I want
to move up a topic attic because we got
clowns on and this is Kings topic and
this is important to us old G's we got
to talk about it so I'm gonna move up
this topic and that is uh I have to give
a eulogy man toys-r-us lord King step
over your topic when you introduce know
that when I do that and then you can go
at me okay your permission to do that
next week
don't worry good I'll be back anyway
I saw my childhood dead I looked at it
and I said the song played in my head I
don't want to grow up
I saw Geoffrey and I'm leaving five
billion in debt and they got a chance
from last year they went to courts last
year they weren't able to pay out on
that debt and they have to shatter all
700 North American stores and that is
also going to spread towards the
European stores and stuff like that um
the reason why this thing is shutting
down and everybody's going to point to
Amazon and Portico Amazon the evil
genius and the manipulation of how they
killed the brick-and-mortar stores where
you went and got your toys that didn't
kill it your cellphone killed it hmm
your cell phone allowed you to pick up
your phone and some order from the
comfort of your home and your wallet
just store you wherever you out you're
walking tell me right now
you want something you pick up your
phone you click it you don't have to go
to a store mm-hmm some people don't even
we got to the point where we're so
impatient
we don't even stand in line at the
checkout counter we go to checkout so we
know better we know ourselves we don't
need help
so no longer going to the store looking
for that new toy because their new toys
flashed on your app and it told you that
it was there so these children don't
really play with toys anyway my son is 8
years old he has two toy bins full of
toys and he plays his xbox is
playstation his DF anything but get down
on that floor and use your imagination
buh-bye so I bring it to you and I know
I lost a piece of me
mm-hmm when it's gone it's gone it's
gone it's gone like blockbuster yeah
gone and it's never coming back I want
to know what was she doing and how did
you feel because I know Lord clowns
beautiful illustrious gaming history and
I know somewhere in there Toys R Us
plays a part in his development oh yeah
definitely
let's go clowns who gives a eulogy going
on man we need you to say some words we
go to song no I play Lord addict for
hunting down Geoffrey I mean it's so sad
because that thing was like you know
this hype for the 80s hmm you know you
wanted something you went to Toys R Us
they had it they had everything man like
even those rare x-men figures that came
out my 12 is they were at Toys R Us you
can find Iceman in those cases and those
boxes once they unloaded it it waited at
the door like I did many hours for it
it's just sad man like and to see all
those employees that worked there that
love the legacy Toys R Us I went to the
one in Brandon Florida the other day and
the guy was like almost crying at the
checkout counter the guy working there
he's like man I grew up in Toys R Us I
want to work here this is my dream job
and now we're closing down no it's so
sad so sad oh and then you know I wanted
to say thank and then there's the crazy
vultures at Toys R Us all of a sudden
because they're closing I want there the
other day for some Funko pop figures
right and there was a father and a son
there and the guy didn't you know he
mostly shopped at Amazon or whatever
probably cuz he was just telling his kid
he's like grab everything Toys R Us
exclusive throating the
I want it water right now and if
someone's like going down i'll phrenic
throw everything in the cart literally
and I got the last Raven figure and he
was so mad it's come to this that
they're popular now because they're
going bankrupt
thanks now everybody's going there and
the Lions are crowded and they're
looking for deals and soy sauce
exclusives instead of just enjoying you
know that good ol smell when you walk in
and you know the bicycles put together
in the back for you and those sand boxes
at the front with the sandbags man I
missed those game cages I used to have
you know where you take that slip slip
you had that one employee that was like
privileged with the keys like yeah he's
like I got urban champion right here for
nest moment one of the kids in the
eighties Toys R Us commercial was Jaleel
White Stieg Steve Urkel I never did it
was continued little clouds but I take
his back man you know I wasn't there the
other day I was passing by Taurus
employees and he was like you know one
of the older guys he just wanted to
probably retire or something and I
overheard a customer trying to bribe him
customers like I got 70 bucks here can
you hold some exclusives for me so they
come off the truck next week I don't
give a [ __ ] we're closing so yeah and
I'm sitting there like what I'm a real
kid here did you
oh boy do I go back to those commercials
and I still watch them and I really hope
you know the the CEO said that after the
bankruptcy which is gonna happen on
Tuesday in court they're gonna start
slashing prices Tuesday afternoon or
something like that but he's trying to
hold out a few stores after bankruptcy
in hopes of a buyer so maybe me and Lord
King can start like a GoFundMe or
Kickstarter for the five billion or
something you know maybe do this
takeover join us on actually engage you
know not plan when I say that I honestly
believe there's a lot of 80s and 70s
babies down don't want to see it go and
I will be me a clowns will be perfect
owners because we will bring it back and
bring it to this new digital age where
attic shop when it comes to that I just
wanted like a halo Cognito what is the
stopping arrangement the Lord King makes
Amazon shop today drop I do do that
and if I can't find something like when
I go get my amiibos that's the only
place I shop at the finals exclusives
just out there like twice a year my gosh
I'm not lying
I guess you're right yeah that is true I
will admit my fault to you at
hey toys all right me Lord clowns will
bring it to this new age that's right
we'll hold video game competitions there
we'll get some executives over there for
the fans lizdavid let me jump in right
quick mags this would oh this would hurt
it's for her I mean got the information
from King and then clowns file it up I
want to shout out all old-school style
in the chat local style man he actually
has a fantastic article right now up on
TRC gen com1 Toys R Us and on full
disclosure I'm gonna put your business
out there cuz you put it in the article
he was a manager one of the closing
stores to close it and shout that
lordose cool styled and I'm saying
holding it down but um yeah he had a
good point he just said like kids you
know they got handheld systems like the
switch
you know tablets like yeah iPod you know
smart phones are like the new
walkie-talkies you know puzzles and
board games no one's buying it you can
get online you know it was basically one
of these things where they were just
being reactive you know any times are
just changing on them in front of them
and then you know compound that with
Amazon launching your infamous a shout
out to them is so convenient I can just
press a button and literally order
everything I have the online retail
space is so big and then he also made a
good point in reference to um Walmart
and Target you know when it came down to
just don't that pricing and being ultra
competitive Toys R Us could not compete
with that and it just ultimately led to
their downfall on the debt you know it
was just unsurmountable the problem with
that was the fact that once once they
had all that debt right then you would
think that the answer to that is to get
more investors to eat up that debt and
what happened was instead that they took
the company private wants to take the
company private that debt is yours and
no one else you have no one else to help
you pay down and then and then it
happened at a time when like you said
all of these other companies are
evolving to include everything that Toys
R Us does as it is Max and it turned
into a thing with it they didn't have
the capital to reinvest in us change
into changing their image
mom many you know the writing was on the
wall when you see something like FAO
Schwartz go down FAO Schwartz FAO
Schwartz you know went down because the
fact that it's it was the most expensive
place to shop for toys that said that is
Nirvana for toys it wasn't known enough
for toys like if you walk into FAO
Schwartz they get the experience that
you're supposed to have when you're
walking in into a toy store it felt like
a dream moving into that store
absolutely and that's what toys that
rust never was able to capture like it
just when you walk into Toys R Us it
looks like a warehouse it looks like a
cavernous sort of warehouse right you
know you know the staff that's there is
very thinly spread out that you kind of
run around and do your own thing and it
just doesn't feel like this joyous
experience they should be having when
you're shopping for toys and it just
it's a sad thing man when you think
about that you think about like when
Lionel kitty City went out of business
window when the Wiz went out of business
these are are like four eighties kids
these are loves remember yeah things
remember and it's a sad thing that you
know in and in like I said you know and
Toys R Us this case a lot of it really
wasn't their fault like all these
companies have a lot of debt but once
you do things once you do things in in
opposition to fixing that debt it was
only a matter of time
I just want to pile on I mean shout out
to the chauchat is a lot of 82 seventies
kids everybody's going deaf singing
right Maxie talking real transform
there's a lot of real transformer I see
going on and I got a comment on it you
know saying I got to get a little motion
it's my first ever time at choice
Russell's my dad he took me there and um
this is g1 error and I got devastated
for the first time it was six six in the
box baby remember the sticks in the wood
yeah it was just such a you know I'm
saying joyous thing used to get like I
just so look forward to it like we're
good you get sent to Toys R Us you know
and you get to GI Joe's with the kungfu
grip no I will say one thing why do you
guys know
especially people who follow planted
Xbox that I used to play you hear a lot
and they actually held regionals and
stuffs at Toys R Us
like if you if you won you got these
little point things you can go to Toys R
Us Toys R Us and you can cash them in
for packs like that's the only
experience I have with Toys R Us at
least em happy I wonder if there one
time with my cousin store and my cousin
sage and his dad bought them a Gamecube
and then that's the only time I've ever
been in that store she's proud did she
actually was able to at least go in
because I again clowns no there there's
one here in our mall damn it go now
before all the dads take the exclusives
the clown's nose like it was so
important because as a child like that
was despite it was like yeah it was like
an amusement park for a kid and you came
in there and you had so much joy in your
heart because you knew you were gonna
get something it was just oh man I
literally had some of my favorite toys
ever at Toys R Us like I said the
Transformers the GI Joes soft always to
get everything and for me it was
Christmas time because when I was when I
was old enough when I was old enough to
be you know to be privy to their - to
the realness find out about Santa Claus
right so I was I was allowed to go on to
the toy shop each trip you know that was
a big thing for me I'm like I'm in the
in-crowd I'm an adult now it was such it
was so much you know be walking between
my mom and my dad and they'd be using me
to pick the toys cuz I'm the kid so I'm
I know what's what they liked what they
asked for whatnot and it was just such
an amazing experience I'll always
remember that sad thing that it that
sort of stuff just doesn't have sound
grabs the hostage was talking about the
trip because that was the place to go
away if you win anyplace else looking
for Transformers they really didn't have
a large selection actually they had they
own aisle
that's where I got the whole what was
that um the thing that we got be where
well it was a racetrack was like a no
there was the world the biggest trap
they had that like Fortress Maximus or
whatever I forgot the corn was the one
that had a track that Omega had the
track we had to try again the tank that
went on the track that went around it's
so many truth
it's like exclusive stuff that you could
not find anywhere I defy you to find it
on eBay right now you're look at the
prices you put that camera on and show
us that there because I didn't have one
of those fantastic mom's like you say
Lord Fritos oh that's a super pops yes
super pops yes
my daddy was not around oh but shout out
to Lord Kratos whose mom's held down all
his collection of video games and stuff
like that
my mom moved my mom's do my stuff to the
left mint condition g1 all of it oh my
god oh my god let's rob him now
no this brothel that was his New York
City Bronx he said you got to be my
[Applause]
always collected them and then um I
guess in the early in the early 2000s
when it was people were buying stuff
offline and stuff the beginnings of the
eBay stuff and all that he got into
buying and and selling and he made he
made some good money buying and selling
and the process was able to complete his
g1 collection so he has everything in
boxes yeah we go all the door about as
bad it's a sad time with so many
memories bad log kings and this we got
to pour a little look out bet it's this
is what hurts the Lord's we have all oh
Jesus okay you know said this this one
hit hard Lord clouds definitely brought
that to my attention I was like man it's
gonna be tough to go do this oh yeah we
got we gotta give a shout yeah the red
bird oh yeah thanks for everybody coming
through it now let me see it ups get
this a-hole going in you know I'm saying
we got the new pole obviously with the
recent announcements obviously by
Microsoft regarding the future of Xbox
in its cloud gaming division how
confident are you that Microsoft stays
committed to the console market a very
confident cloud services approach is
just to supplement their reach be not
confident I can see a multi-platform
Xbox app in the future see I don't care
crackdown 3 is the power to cloud baby
so this is question those are the
choices please Rock the Vote at the ILP
Twitter polls heart when it goes up Lord
clowns an absolute pleasure to have you
finally in the realm every Thursday
night usually at 7:00 or 7:30 p.m. for
guys with quarters on YouTube twists
Twitter our for gwq podcast on Twitter
it's basically like everywhere at this
point on Google search we show up
nice nice no they've actually put a lot
of fun stores and shout out we're gonna
bring you and your father back from the
next no my dad had a good hook up at
Toys R Us grown up actually bribe at
midnight when there's some of the trucks
payments my dad was there and the
employees unloaded them they were gonna
actually bring them up at the cash
register and then be like ah here you go
here's the whole box of ice man that's
rare way more kognito was talking
earlier there wouldn't be no absolute
get you back God also infernal huge fame
for guys Accord is CP I can't pronounce
the CB is it CPC I yes I'm a pest
control incorporated assassin Lord
addict humour that just comes in out of
nowhere
Brian sarcastic yes it's like very dry
it's funny man just to give it is
absolutely love to show huge huge fans
just want to shout out real quick before
we do our outros on this is from D
actually the inner circle now please go
there's a ultimate sea of thieves gives
away on T icgn comm is by our friends at
the double xp shot to fame and the crew
this is your chance
I can win a physical copy of the game as
well as the Xbox wireless controller
that that limited-edition joint the
custom one so please go to TI CG is one
thing I just posted the interview too
nicely and we got a shout out to take
last night
Craig Duncan interview was late TRC Sdn
is doing it big yard you gotta check
that interview out really really dope
Craig Duncan you know I'm saying you
know who he is he a devious coming so we
got a lot of stuff cooking with that but
please make sure you get on that
giveaway it's one day away so let's get
our outros poppin Lord addict my brother
from another mother co-host with the
cold most came through I'm very happy I
know you'll be able to make it today so
it's good to hear you and hear you fight
with us about the cloud and the features
Xbox that was fun
we're gonna find people find you when
you got cooking up well you definitely
won't find me in a Toys R Us no but I
appreciate for coming by when uh you
guys started talking about the god award
day I was literally looking through my
friend's house like like crazy looking
throw I was like they gotta be a head
like a headphone or a mic or something
about this note now like I didn't the
processor can like register me talking a
lot better so like I actually come
through clear what I have a mic now I
was like the first thing I thought I
even lie I was like king is dog Lord
what's going on with you awaken to find
people not find you online clowns for
coming through man appreciate naps so
we're all here with us with us fools on
here
but yeah definitely you can find me find
me next week plan way out with Lord King
go
the profiles offline and anonymous in my
jet jump in jump in essex all go play
gonna get into some seeds as well um and
I might me I'm gonna visit my friend mr.
Lee here maybe pick up an early copy of
the show nice
Sabra coming back home to the show baby
so we go that you got a comebacker they
got a Yankee in the causeway to that
copy comes get that state of decay to
yours a shout-out to say Lord King with
the with the with the beautiful
testifying this morning had to church
all energized was really really
emotional I'm living on portal in some
others places now that we are we have in
our possession a GoPro Hero at PAX East
and III full force we're gonna give as
we get close to these dates like little
King said it's going to be a movie and
we gonna have a lot of information to
share and we get regards to those events
absolutely what about with it fine
people can find you act in the meantime
before xbox360 loverro one does look
I've you know here the game
this has been spread once again thank
you so much Lord clouds are coming
through dealing with all the shenanigans
and foolishness of the Lord
Claire they were to get through it oh I
guess they shout out make sure you guys
hit that up the unit circle Network
subscribe like those likes really
appreciated we'll be going up tomorrow
thank you guys on the I just got crap
[Music]
like I said there's a sec favorable ooh
we got multiverses up tomorrow also
thank you guys for supporting flashpoint
number eight is up with Ibanez on the on
Lord podcast YouTube channel thanks for
the support there on that passion
project now and it is something thanks
for rocking with us everybody enjoy this
Sunday have a good one and we will catch
you next week peace